>>> TONIGHT SENATOR KYRSTEN
SINEMA IS INSISTING HER DECISION
TO SWITCH FR DEMOCRAT TO
INDEPENDENT WON'T CHANGE HOW SHE
DOES HER JOB.
LET'S GET SOME MORE OF SENATOR
SINEMA'S EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW
WITH CNN AND WHAT HER NEW STATUS
MEANS FOR THE STATE OF PLAY IN
WASHINGTON.
JESSICA DEAN IS JOINING US LIVE
FROM CAPITOL HILL.
JESSICA, A HUGE CURVEBALL FROM
SENATOR SINEMA TODAY.
>> Reporter: IT CERTAINLY WAS,
WOLF.
THIS HAS BEEN A BIG WEEK FOR
SENATE DEMOCRATS, GETTING THAT
51-SEAT MAJORITY ON TUESDAY,
REALLY CELEBRATING.
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER CHUCK
SCHUMER IS SO EXCITED TO HAVE
THAT MAJORITY.
AND THEN TODAY THIS HUGE NEWS.
FRIDAY BROUGHT A BOMBSHELL FOR
SENATE DEMOCRATS.
>> I'VE REGISTERED AS AN ARIZONA
INDEPENDENT.
>> Reporter: ARIZONA SENATOR
KYRSTEN SINEMA, A MODERATE WHO
WIELDED ENORMOUS POWER IN THE
EVENLY SPLIT SENATE OF THE LAST
TWO YEARS, TELLING CNN'S JAKE
TAPPER, SHE HAS LEFT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND IS NOW AN
INDEPENDENT.
>> I'M JUST NOT WORRIED ABOUT
FOLKS WHO MAY NOT LIKE THIS
APPROACH.
WHAT I AM WORRIED ABOUT IS
CONTINUING TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT
FOR MY STATE.
>> Reporter: FOLLOWING HER
ANNOUNCEMENT, SINEMA TALKED WITH
REPORTERS AT AN ARIZONA FOOD
BANK ON FRIDAY, SAYING SHE'S NOT
FOCUSED ON RE-ELECTION, BUT ON
HER CONSTITUENTS.
HER TERM IS UP IN 2024.
>> TODAY'S ANNOUNCEMENT IS A
REFLECTION OF MY VALUES AND I
THINK THE VALUES OF MOST
ARIZONANS, WHO ARE TIRED OF A
POLITICAL SYSTEM THAT PULLS
PEOPLE TO THE EDGES AND REALLY
DOESN'T REFLECT WHO WE ARE AS A
PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: SINEMA GAVE THE
WHITE HOUSE AND SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER ADVANCED
WARNING OF HER ANNOUNCEMENT.
ON FRIDAY SCHUMER SAID IN A
STATEMENT, SINEMA WILL KEEP HER
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS, ADDING,
QUOTE, I BELIEVE SHE'S A GOOD
AND EFFECTIVE SENATOR, AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO A PRODUCTIVE
SESSION IN THE NEW DEMOCRATIC
MAJORITY SENATE.
WE WILL MAINTAIN OUR NEW
MAJORITY ON COMMITTEES, EXERCISE
OUR SUBPOENA POWER, AND BE ABLE
TO CLEAR NOMINEES WITHOUT
DISCHARGE VOTES.
FELLOW SENATE DEMOCRATS AND THE
WHITE HOUSE ECHOING THAT
SENTIMENT, SAYING SINEMA'S
DECISION WON'T CHANGE MUCH.
>> IF SHE WERE TO SAY, NO, I'M
GOING OVER REPUBLICAN, I AM NOT
VOTING WITH THEM ANYMORE, THAT'S
A WHOLE DIFFERENT THING.
THAT IS NOWHERE NEAR WHAT SHE
SAID, AND SHE HAS TENDED NOT TO
GO TO THE CAUCUS MEETING,
SOMETHING SHE SAID SO I'M NOT
TELLING SOMETHING OUT OF SCHOOL,
EXCEPT FOR RARE MOMENTS WHERE
SHE'S ADVOCATING FOR SOMETHING
SHE CARES ABOUT.
AND THAT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE
EITHER.
>> Reporter: PRACTICALLY,
DEMOCRATS WILL MAINTAIN THEIR
MAJORITY WITH THREE INDEPENDENTS
NOW.
PLENTY OF DEMOCRATS HAVE SHARPLY
CRITICIZED THE MOVE.
ARIZONA REPRESENTATIVE REUBEN
BLASTED THE MOVE SAYING
UNFORTUNATELY SENATOR SINEMA IS
ONCE AGAIN PUTTING HER OWN
INTEREST AHEAD OF GETTING THINGS
DONE FOR ARIZONANS.
WHEN IT COMES TO DAY-TO-DAY
OPERATIONS OF THE SENATE MOVING
FORWARD, IT'S WORTH UNDERSCORING
SHE'S KEEPING THE COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS.
THAT MEANS DEMOCRATS ARE GOING
TO HOLD MAJORITY AND STILL BE
ABLE TO EXERCISE A LOT OF THE
POWER THEY WERE EXCITED TO GET
WITH THE 51-SEAT MAJORITY.
THE BIG QUESTIONS THAT ARE GOING
TO BEGIN TO POSSIBLE UP AND CROP
UP IS WHAT HAPPENS IN 2024 WHEN
SHE'S UP FOR RE-ELECTION, IF SHE
CHOOSES TO RUN AGAIN WILL
DEMOCRATS FIELD A CANDIDATE
AGAINST HER?
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
THAT'S WHAT WE'LL KEEP OUR EYE
ON.
>> GOOD POINT.
STAY WITH US.
I WANT TO BRING IN CNN'S CHIEF
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT, PHIL
MATTINGLY AND COMMENTATOR
SMERCONISH.
BEHIND THE SCENES, DID THIS TAKE
SOME OF THE WIND OUT OF THEIR
SALES AFTER THEY JUST CELEBRATED
BIG TIME THE DEMOCRATS' TWO-SEAT
MARGIN, THE MAJORITY THEY HAVE
IN THE SENATE?
>> WOLF, THERE'S NO QUESTION
IT'S BEEN A WHIPSAW OF A WEEK
BASED ON WHAT HAPPENED TUESDAY
VERSUS WHAT HAPPENED TODAY.
ONE OFFICIAL I SPOKE TO JUST A
SHORT WHILE AGO CAPTURED IT BEST
WHEN HE SAID IT COULD HAVE BEEN
WORSE.
THAT'S KIND OF HOW WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS VIEWED IT.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THIS WAS A
SURPRISE AND THIS ISN'T
SOMETHING THEY WANTED TO HEAR,
AND THEY DID HEAR IT DIRECTLY
FROM SINEMA'S TEAM.
THEY WERE INFORMED BEFORE THE
DECISION WAS ANNOUNCED.
SHE IS STAYING ON COMMITTEES AT
HER REQUEST, SENATOR CHUCK
SCHUMER SAYING THAT WOULD WORK.
SHE HAS VOTED WITH THE PRESIDENT
93% OF THE TIME OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS AND THERE IS A VERY
STRONG VIEW THAT PARTICULARLY ON
THE ISSUES THEY FEEL LIKE THEY
CAN MAKE A LOT OF PROGRESS ON
WITH THE EXPANDED MAJORITY, MOST
NOTABLY ON NOMINATIONS, SHE HAS
PROVEN SHE WILL BE THERE WHEN
THEY NEED HER.
THEY DON'T SEE ANY CHANGE TO
THAT AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
I THINK THERE'S AN UNDERCURRENT
THAT WILL BECOME MORE APPARENT
IN THE WEEKS AHEAD AND THAT'S
THE SYMBOLISM OF A CRITICAL
MODERATE DECIDING TO LEAVE THE
CAUCUS, WHAT THAT MEANS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION, WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR DEMOCRATS HEADING INTO A
PRESIDENTIAL CYCLE, SOMETHING
THEY NEED TO GRAPPLE WITH.
>> GOOD POINT.
MICHAEL, SENATOR SINEMA SAYS SHE
DOESN'T FIT NEATLY INTO EITHER
POLITICAL PARTY'S BOX.
IS THAT SOMETHING VOTERS OUT
THERE RELATE TO?
>> AMEN.
THERE ARE SO MANY WHO FEEL, JUST
AS SHE FEELS.
YOU KNOW, WOLF, I'VE HEARD RED
WATCHED A LOT OF CYNICISM TODAY
FROM FOLKS WHO SAY IT'S ONLY
ABOUT SURVIVAL, IT'S A TECHNIQUE
FOR HER TO EVADE A PRIMARY IN
TWO YEARS AND THEN SECURE
RE-ELECTION.
MY GLASS IS HALF FULL.
I LOOK AT IT DIFFERENTLY.
I THINK THAT SENATOR SINEMA
CHOOSES TO BE ONE AMONG THE 35%
OF US WHO, ACCORDING TO GALLOP,
AND THAT NUMBER HAS BEEN HIGHER
WHO SAY I'M NOT SERVED BY THE Rs
OR Ds, I'M AN I.
AND THE NUMBER IS ABOUT THE SAME
IN ARIZONA.
TO THE EXTENT IT IS A SURVIVAL
TECHNIQUE, IT SAYS SOMETHING
VERY SAD ABOUT PRIMARIES IN
GENERAL, LOOK AT JEFF FLAKE AND
KYRSTEN SINEMA, THE IDEA THERE'S
NO ROOM FOR NUANCE AND YOU'VE
GOT TO BE FAR TO THE LEFT OR
RIGHT AND YOU CAN'T GET
NOMINATED.
THAT'S NOT WHERE MOST OF THE
COUNTRY IS.
MOST OF THE COUNTRY IS SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN THOSE POLAR EXTREMES.
SO TO THE EXTENT SHE WANTS TO
GIVE VOICE TO THOSE OF US CLOSER
TO THE MIDDLE, I'M ALL FOR IT.
>> GOOD POINT.
JESSICA, LET'S TURN TO THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES WHERE KEVIN
McCARTHY'S QUEST TO BECOME THE
NEXT SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE IS
BECOMING INCREASINGLY TENSE
RIGHT NOW, AS YOU WELL KNOW.
WHAT SORT OF CONCESSIONS IS
McCARTHY CONSIDERING IN ORDER TO
SECURE THE 218 VOTES HE NEEDS TO
BECOME THE SPEAKER?
>> WELL, WE KNOW, WOLF, THAT HE
IS MEETING VERY PRIVATELY AND
SERIOUSLY WITH A LOT OF THESE
CONSERVATIVES HE NEEDS TO SWAY
AND MAKE SURE HE HAS ON HIS SIDE
WHEN THIS COMES TO A FLOOR VOTE
IN JANUARY WHEN HE TRIES TO GET
TO 218 VOTES.
HE NEEDS TO GET THERE, HE ONLY
HAS FOUR TO SPARE.
SO IT'S NOT A LOT.
AND HE'S HAD FIVE COME OUT AND
SAY THAT THEY WILL NOT VOTE FOR
HIM.
THERE'S ONE THAT SAYS HE'S A
LITTLE BIT GETTABLE.
SO MAYBE THERE'S SOME WIGGLE
ROOM THERE.
SO HE DOES HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO TO GET TO THAT NUMBER.
AND TO THAT END, WE KNOW A
COUPLE OF THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, HE HAS BEEN TALKING
TO THIS GROUP OF CONSERVATIVES
ABOUT COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS,
KIND OF HIGH PROFILE COMMITTEES,
COMMITTEES LIKE THE RULES
COMMITTEE WHICH SETS THE RULE
FOR HOW DIFFERENT LEGISLATION
WILL COME TO THE FLOOR.
THAT'S PRETTY POWERFUL.
THE OTHER THING, THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO DRIVE THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS MORE.
SO IT'S ABOUT TRYING TO
NEGOTIATE WITH THEM AND GET THEM
ON BOARD.
THE QUESTION IS, WOLF, CAN HE DO
THAT?
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT'S ENOUGH
TO GET THEM ON HIS SIDE BY
JANUARY 3rd?
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
MICHAEL, IF THE HOUSE GOP CAN'T
EVEN GET ON THE SAME PAGE ABOUT
THEIR LEADERSHIP, WHAT MIGHT
THIS MEAN FOR THEIR ABILITY TO
GET THINGS DONE IN THE NEW
CONGRESS?
>> THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO HERD CATS.
IT'S A MATHEMATICAL EQUATION.
HE CAN AFFORD TO LOSE FOUR AND
THUS FAR IT LOOKS LIKE HE'S
GOING TO LOSE FIVE.
IF THAT'S THE SITUATION, THEN
HE'S EITHER GOT TO MAKE A DEAL
WITH THE CONSERVATIVE MEMBERS OF
THE CAUCUS OR REACH ACROSS THE
AISLE AND SEE IF THERE'S SOME
WIGGLE ROOM FOR NEGOTIATION WITH
THE Ds.
BUT IN TERMS OF WHAT CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED, LET'S NOT FORGET
THAT DEMOCRATS STILL MAINTAIN
CONTROL OF THE SENATE AND THE
WHITE HOUSE.
SO THERE'S NOTHING LEGISLATIVELY
I THINK IS GOING TO COME OUT OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
I DO BELIEVE THEY'